le projet de loi bioéthique et la pma
pour tout le parlement peut-il trouver
un consensus
c'est le face à face et nos invités ce
soir virginie thelen fondatrice et
déléguée générale de l'avenir pour tous
opposés au projet de loi et fatima
benomar militante féministe cofondatrice
de l'association les effrontés es
favorables au texte bonsoir mesdames
virginie telle haine
il y à une manifestation donc ce soir à
paris on l'a vu avec katia pique nique
en direct de cette manifestation le fait
de manifester est ce que ça peut changer
la donne
on parle d'un feu vert parlementaire
début juillet même s'il ya beaucoup
d'amendements katia l'a rappelé
notamment déposés par les républicains
oui enfin moi je tiens à dire que comme
vous le voyez je ne suis pas dans la
manifestation parce que je ne suis pas
sûr de m'opposer à cette loi pour les
mêmes raisons que les gens qui sont dans
la rue c'est à dire qu'en fait pour nous
à l'avenir pour tous
je rappelle que j'avais mené les
manifestations 2013
non pas contre le couple homosexuel non
pas contre l'union des homosexuels
mais peut on ne change pas la filiation
génétique des enfants tout en
reconnaissant une filiation sociale des
parents éducateurs
or cette loi de pma dans ce projet là
c'est pas le principe de la pma étendue
aux femmes qui vivent pas avec des
hommes qui nous pose un problème c'est
que justement elle ne donne pas assez de
choix à ces femmes c'est à dire que si
elles veulent faire leur bébé avec un
ami un géniteur connu qui viendrait
faire l'insémination en direct chez le
gynécologue et bien elles ne le peuvent
pas c'est totalement interdit parce
qu'elles n'ont droit que finalement qu'à
du sperme anonyme du sperme qui peut
être manipulées génétiquement peut-être
plus tard et en tout cas elle passait
par une fécondation in vitro qu'il
laisse peser énormément de doutes sur
l'intégrité génétique des embryons
voilà notre problématique nous
pour une pma ouvert à toutes les femmes
mais aussi à tous les hommes si elles le
souhaitent
fatima benomar regardez ce qu'a dit
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat passer en
force sur le projet de loi de bioéthique
ce qui est inconcevable pour un sujet
aussi sensible ces débats sociétaux et
bioéthique doivent être remis à plus
tard qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
passer en force au parlement est ce que
c'est pas antidémocratique
je ne vois absolument pas comment on
peut dire que c'est toi est en train de
passer en force déjà il fait un
consensus politique au sens démocratique
puisque ça fait dix ans qu'on nous la
promet que des candidats à la
présidentielle la mettent dans leurs
programmes et elles gagnent les
élections
et là ça fait deux ans que cette loi est
examinée ça a été une promesse de
campagne deux fois l'opinion publique
est majoritairement favorable
l'ordre des médecins le comité
consultatif national d'éthique tout le
monde en fait la valise ne voit pas de
problème et ça fait dix ans surtout
qu'ils aient des projets parentaux sont
suspendus dans l'espoir que cette loi va
à chaque fois passé il ya des femmes des
couples de femmes ou des femmes
célibataires qui disent bon je ne vais
pas aller me ruiner en belgique ou en
espagne
parce que on promet que dans un an deux
ans je vais pouvoir enfin mener à bien
mon projet parental
donc comment on peut dire qu'elle passe
en force alors qu'on a eu dans ce
quinquennat des états généraux de la
bioéthique en 2018 l'étude du conseil
d'état la vie du comme je vous ai dit du
ccn
le rapport de la mission d'information
sur la bioéthique en 2019 et tous disent
qu'il ya aucun problème éthique a laissé
les femmes en couple ou ayant un projet
parental passer par une pma et donc
comme on n'admet pas ces familles qui ne
sont pas aux yeux du reste de la société
entre guillemets traditionnelle en ferme
les yeux sur ce qui existe dans la
société c'est à dire déjà des familles
recomposées déjà des parents par
ailleurs hétérosexuels qui ont acquis
qui utilisent la pma qui est sécurisé
sanitairement des pma l'étranger des pma
artisanat c'est à dire des femmes qui
mettent en danger leur santé justement
en allant chercher du sperme comme elles
peuvent
et en ce 1 c'est maintenant on va dire
avec les moyens du bord et en laissant
de côté la sécurisation juridique de ses
enfants
on avait déjà eu un débat assez médiocre
sur le mariage pour tous si on voit
quelques années plus tard qu'aujourd'hui
il est consensuel et je peux vous
assurer que si la pma pour tout passe
elle sera consensuelle dans quelques
années on se souviendra avec un peu de
honte de la manière dont sont biaisés le
débat aujourd'hui mais je n'étais là
nous voulait réagir
oui alors je dois m'inscrire en faux
les états généraux de la bioéthique ont
ouvert une grande consultation nationale
sur lequel la pma pour toutes sans homme
sans le choix de pouvoir venir avec un
homme et ça je serais heureuse d'avoir
quand même votre avis sur cette option
qui n'est pas dans la loi et bien cette
pma pour toutes avait été rejeté à 90 %
donc chers jeunes chères amies quand
vous nous parler de consensus national
il n'existe pas quand vous voyez à quel
point le scénar vide entièrement le
texte et d'ailleurs je le déplore
moi je voudrais qu'il soit amendé
renforcée pour que l'on puisse faire des
enfants avec un homme et une femme
il comprit nano cohabitant pas ensemble
et ça on n'y a pas droit
donc ya pas de consensus non plus pour
ceux qui veulent une extension de la
procréation entre mes femmes au libre
choix des femmes et des hommes
et ça nous ne l'avons pas donc a pas de
consensus chers amis mais en fait le
consensus n'est pas d'unanimité ça c'est
sûr qu'on aura jamais tous les hommes et
les femmes politiques et tous les
citoyens qui sont d'accord sur quelque
chose
ce que je dis c'est qu'il ya un
consensus dans le sens où il ya une
majorité qui s'est dessinée et des
candidats qui ont gagné maintenant bien
ensemble
tendu moi je vais vous le dire cette loi
est insuffisante ne serait ce que parce
qu'on a écarté mais là les sommes
transmises en france qu'ils ont ils ont
un appareil génital
ils peuvent tomber enceinte et je suis
sûr que la société est prête pour ça si
vous vous souvenez avec une émission
prévue par les jeunes s'étaient
secretstory ou qui avait porté à la
finale le premier rhum enceinte c'est à
dire une personne qui étaient des femmes
et qui avait décidé de changer de genre
et qui était tombée enceinte et tout le
monde adorait cette histoire et y était
très sensible et
ne voyais pas ce personnage commun 16
ans et par rapport à ce que vous dites
oui il ya bien l'insémination par sperme
congelé c'était vrai que parfois il ya
des parents qui veulent plus tard
pouvoir faire un enfant et qui peuvent
s'assimiler avec du sperme
maintenant ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
par rapport à la filiation puisque vous
en parliez c'est qu'on ne peut pas
demander aux géniteurs à la personne qui
fournit le sperme genre dix ans plus
tard ou vingt ans plus tard d'assumer
des responsabilités parentales qui n'a
pas assez pour ça que la filiation
sociale nerfs fatima ça n'est pas ce que
je dis fatima ça n'est pas du tout ce
que je dis je ne parle pas de cette
situation là si en amont de la pma
puisqu'on doit passer devant le notaire
ça c'est prévu dans la loi l'article 4
jeux nous disons nous à l'avenir pour
tout ce qu il faudrait pouvoir perd pas
c'est aussi avec une personne qui sera
présente à la fécondation mais qui pour
autant ne sera pas reconnu comme le
parent éducateur
en fait nous voulons plusieurs modes de
filiation et nous n'en avons qu'un sens
en passe de l'homme et à la femme a deux
hommes deux femmes enfin à deux femmes
en l'occurrence et j'ai même pas
pourquoi pas aux hommes d'ailleurs bon
nous nous disons il va manquer quelqu'un
dans le couple des deux femmes
il va manquer quelqu'un à cet enfant qui
pourrait très bien être présente dans
l'univers sans pour autant être décrétée
comme le père ayant l'autorité parentale
mais comme station si bien né dans un
géniteur connu que l'enfant puisse
savoir où est le père et qu'on passe pas
par un vaste marché mondialisé de
procréation de reproduction qui permet
toutes les manipulations génétiques
parce que le vrai problème ce sont les
manipulations génétiques justement
justement mesdames et mesdames
me permets de 11 à 17 avec les embryons
chimérique
ils sont justement jusqu'avant regarder
ce qu'il a dit l'eurodéputé l'est
républicain françois-xavier bellamy il a
dit c'est le sait le fait même d'être
humain que l'on va transformer il évoque
donc la suppression du critère
d'infertilité
à ceux qui parlent de bébé éprouvette
vous répondez quoi fatima alors déjà il
faut savoir que comment ça se passe des
médecins qui permettent d'avoir un
enfant en fait c'est un corps de rêve
par la loi biologique il ya des couples
qui sont dits infertiles mais c'est très
rare les couples qui sont tous les deux
stérile à 100%
en fait ma vie un couple sur six en
france qui a des difficultés pour avoir
des enfants est d'ailleurs chez près de
10% des couples infertiles aucune cause
n'est identifié donc un moment inédit
qu'il ya une indication médicale il ya
le le médecin qui a sa discrétion du bon
bah je pense que vous êtes éligible à
une pma parce que ça fait deux ans que
vous essayez je vois bien que vous n'y
arrivez pas donc cet argument de
l'infertilité en soit il est en général
il se fait à la discrétion de
l'indication médicale donc de toute
manière ça fait des années que les pma
sont autorisèrent ne parle absolument
pas d'une nouvelle pratique qui existe
on juste on demande juste en élargir le
public mais ça ne va absolument pas
remettre en cause le fait d'être plus
particulièrement axé sur la fertilité
c'est juste qu'il ya des couples qui
n'arrive pas à avoir d'enfants pour des
causes de baisse fertilité c'est très
rarement des infertilités total ou pour
des causes comme dans les couples
lesbiens qui ne peuvent tout simplement
pas se reproduire par voie naturelle et
achats et dans les couples hétérosexuels
c'est à une tierce personne encore une
fois c'est un sport le père biologique
n'est absolument pas le même que le père
sociale et ça n'empêche pas que ça se
passe très très bien bien général oui
mais ça on comprend pourquoi le père
enfin le géniteur biologique a été
décrétée donneur anonyme
c'était pour protéger justement le
couple kate kate n qui souffrait déjà et
ça je pardonnez-moi fatima mais qui qui
eux souffraient d'infertilité au bout de
longues années de pma d'abord par
insémination puis d'accord ils pouvaient
ça prenait du temps moi j'ai pas
commencer une pma mai
on a eu des problèmes au début je vous
assure qu'on attend avant de passer au
stade supérieur
là maintenant la différence c'est comme
de toute façon on n'aura pas préserver
un couple entre hommes et femmes
puisqu'il s'agit d'une femme seule ou de
deux femmes
la loi dit bien à l'article parce que
j'ai la loi ici devant moi dis bien cet
accès ne peut faire l'objet d'aucune
différence de traitement notamment au
regard du statut matrimonial ou de
l'orientation sexuelle des demandeurs ce
que je trouve tout à fait normal noah
l'avenir pour tous mais de ce point de
vue il y aura une différence de
traitement car les femmes en couple avec
un homme pour 11 ans infertilité allait
lancer la pma sans qu'on sache vraiment
justement s'il ya une infertilité ou pas
peut-être même en cas de désaccord avec
leurs maris qui veut plus d'enfants
faire une pma sans l'accord du mari ce
qui va un peu dissocier le couple ne ne
nous cachons pas assez ce problème par
ailleurs les femmes qui sont
célibataires et qui pourrait très bien y
aller avec un ami elles ne pourront pas
il faudra qu'elle mente qu'elle dise
qu'elle soit en coupe ou je sais pas
quoi
alors que les couples les vous en
connaissez certainement fatima parce que
vous êtes beaucoup plus proche il voulut
d'aider des femmes qui vivent en couple
lesbien
il y en a qui veut voudrait faire des
enfants avec un homme elle ne le
pourront pas c'est une 18 l'image de la
santé olivier ferrand qui confirme la
levée de l'anonymat des dons de sperme
attendait ça près à jouer à 18 à 18 ans
je vous parle pas de celle là je vous
parle de faire un enfant en présence
réelle aujourd'hui on dirait en
présentiel chez la gynéco suivi
monitorer pour les deux femmes et
peut-être même pour un couple d'hommes
avec ce n'est pas permis
ces îles et c'est un délit pénal qui est
qui est sanctionné de 30000 euros
d'amendé
et bien voilà nous nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec ça parce que nous voulons
que la procréation soit la plus
naturelle ou naturellement aider aussi
moqué pas de manipulations génétiques
vous comprenez notre position et vous ne
pouvez que nous rejoindre vous êtes
zécolos
dans cette unité je vous rappelle juste
le principe de la faune conditions in
vitro c'est que les ovocytes sont
prélevés par voie vaginale il ya une
mise en présence avec des spermatozoïdes
qui sont préparés sont fécondés qui sont
cultivés non mais avant cela je suis
comblé alors à du congelé il y aura t il
alors à une conversion une conservation
volcy terre on pourra prendre des ovules
congelés on sait pas d'où ils viennent
ils doivent être anonyme
alors moi je vais vous dire même une
chose fatima ça va vous étonner non ça
c'est vous êtes en train de ce pic mais
pas du tout ça va être ouvert aux
cliniques le marché mondial va d'abord
c'est on arrive sur la fin du débat
pardonnez moi je veux terminer
rapidement ce sont les deux en tout cas
moi que vous me facile autant moi je
suis vraiment contre la gpa donc merci
d'avoir lever cette ambiguïté dès le
début dans le reportage
mais sur la question de ceux dont on
parle on n'a jamais vu aujourd'hui en
tout cas de marché liées à la
marchandisation des corps para bd noir
un marché mondialisé les cliniques
reproductive qui ne n'ont pas d'éthique
bondé vous avez ça l'a fait dans la loi
il y aura des établissements privés il
faut encadrer tout ça moi je suis
d'accord qu'on encadre mieux d'antenne
le temps qu'une émission ce terme qui
n'ont qu'à laisser moi vous répondre si
c'était ça votre inquiétude à ce moment
là vous seriez contre la pma tout court
parce que je ne vois pas ce que le fait
de l'étendre aux femmes célibataires et
à toutes les femmes auraient à voir avec
un éventuel extension du marche d'un
marché de vos sites qui n'existe pas
encore donc à ce moment là sur une étude
poussée la pma tour mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui la question ne se pose si
toutefois elle se poser un jour
évidemment que nous on serait contraint
absolument pour tout contre toute
marchandisation vente d'organes tout ce
que vous voulez mais en tout cas ce
n'est pas la problématique qui s'est
alors joueront l'anonymat alors chers
faits l'altima je suis obligé de vous
couper
mesdames version tous les cas d'avoir
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
d'avoir des battues berger de tln je
rappelle que vous êtes fondatrice et
déléguée générale de l'avenir pour tous
et fatima benomar militante féministe
cofondatrice de l'association les
effrontés et
ça